we have to practically develop the
our application and therefore us there
we need to focus only on the code is
we do not have to do it
worry about that of the
infrastructure then configure the i
our servers put the software on it
that serves to put load balancer to understand
how to make them scale how to manage
updates understand how to do it
put more disks less disks more
space in a space these things here that
anyway, someone might like it
generally a developer says instead
no guys let me make me do one then
once one than those who are
the guidelines of how to develop
application on app engine that in
the reality is very few for the rest
think of google to handle it all
the infrastructure behind app
engine works using app engine
works with four different run times
so you can develop using
java using python using pcp
php and experimentally you can also
use or pattern paradigms that you
they use are the same for all
then platforms then change
simply the language with which it is
gone implement and few other things
but basically what you learn
with a language it is worth most
sometimes even with others
as I told you the app engine has the
possibility to scale automatically
so you can say ok I leave with
a china application and use a
my friend and another who is there then later
I do not know of ideas in universities I praise the
work tell your friends about
application circulates begins to become
a thing used however is not yours
problem in the sense that that too
platform that manages it for you
so be careful is the ideal platform
to scale to millions of users but also
for products it seems therefore video kay I have to
do this thing here as i do the
put on you see if base does not go if then
you do not like it and throw away everything or not
you lost time to understand how then
I have to put on a server I have to do
update configurations
etc
so you can use it for many
things and different types of storage that you
you can use relational databases
non relational sky
cloud provider still google also
for himself parts with a closed platform
which remains only within the
google cloud platform more and more a
po all from google cloud platform is
composed of pieces that you can
use together or in contexts
completely different
obviously if you use it together they are
all residents in the
in google infrastructure so you have
of speed performances
more because they are machines that more or
the less they are in the obviously is not
a real LAN but here is to give you a little
an idea, however, nothing prevents you from taking
use these tiles in others
contexts and beyond we say it to yours
application server app engine cries
a whole series of services as per
example a scheduler crohn
mail management queues
users coming out many other things
and you have the opportunity to do the
versioning of your applications e
then we will see it, that is of you
this application is here at the version
1 this application is the version here
2 and the version that is served of
default is version 1 but a 5 per
a hundred of my traffic also goes
version 2 then slowly if you have
developed something new you can
introduce a user wrong to this
new version is passing in a manner
soft to the new version without di
lucca the day zero I turn off a
address and turn on another and who knows
what happens instead like this
softly you can go on and on
you have a set of tools that you
allow you to test yours
so the local application without
having to deploy every time in the
cloud and there are also a whole range of
tools that allow you to program
only in the cloud for example being able to is a
editor that however is not google however it is
a product that I see that you are
evolving a lot where you have yours
the positives do not have to configure
nothing from your car
simply by accessing the site
you have your own environment
programming and then you can also do
deploy directly to appengine
therefore in any place in the world
you connect do and on app engine ci
they are also very many frameworks ed
extensions that slowly the community
he is creating for example the java part
you have spring for the part in
python you have everything django and there are
so many other extensions so it's not that
one says ok hug app engine owe me
Forget everything else Do not embrace ten
gene at most
you need to bring some bookstores
what in app engine but what is there
often and willingly for with
language there is also usable in
app engine just to give you a
fast and architecture we have
practically everything there is
inside app engine
so the president is an application
master who decides who does things
user requests arrive from here
there are in front of the manage
so they go can not that takes in
load I make you take charge
from another he continued to etcetera
and here are all the services therefore
we don't know data store
we have for the part of network we have
the ussr matches the messaging part
by channel
you can send daily mail you have all the
services to manage the information directly
images and user identities
news search map services and the like
storage as I told you before there are
lots of solutions available and has
place since the introduction let's start with
the code first thing to one then today
I will talk about the java part then there will be
alex that will show you something in
python and then there will be michele that will make you
see a bit in php then how to say
everyone is there we will be able to see the
platform in its various
facets
for the java part or anyway for all
for all type of development appengine
we need to install the east of gay lesbians
and contains all the tools necessary for
all the run times however more for java
if you want you can install this plugin
for eclipse that adds some
precisely integrated features
in the editor ie in the eclipse editor
so I don't know you don't have to go to
launch things from command line more
however since this plugin is
just a front end for gay people
actually if you have yours
international content environment
yours your maven and your scripts
of what to deploy what you want
no problem
you can integrate into the former gay
because in any case it is command line
if you have the with the command line at
end one makes the worst magi and therefore
however developed ie downloaded here
the gay ones do a little of everything and the first one
thing to do
create an application the application
it is the container of all that
you will go on to develop inside
the application ok anyway every
application registered to an account
google and now then we'll see it enough
practically defined the name of the
project is an indie project and you have
created your first app engine app
name of the project you can put that
you want project andy must be
design of unique for all
app engine applications created in the world
which means all applications
app engine and run on the domain
dott ap spot dot com and then this one
project and becomes the third domain
level so in this case it will be
jeanclaude dconf punto up spot.com e
this will be the address of your app
ok then if you want to have for example the
your domain to render traffic
and then a arrives www.rai.it and in
reality goes on this part of
application however remember that
this is the address of your app
here once you have water grenade
immediately available a console that there
shows a wealth of information that
then we will go on to analyze later
in addition you also have the app staff that does
see 150,000 different parameters e
measurements of what makes yours
therefore act when called
rl workload etcetera
because this is because app engine
despite the free quotas it has anyway
a type of billing not only use two hours
I use it a day but on resources
consumed
so if you want for example you have billing
on the network part on the part of
storage on the CPU side and many others
what's this
this because because it ensures instead of
wheel 28 point and just pay only
what you really are using e
all these consoles etc will serve you
also to understand how eventually
optimize your application
because maybe you know that anyway
the same things can be done
be done in various ways maybe
it is better to use a service or
one pattern rather than another
because after all it makes you
save a little as you see it
through all these tools here
otherwise one should shoot a little
blindly
then
finished the part of hello world we go to
so do our card then
I'm already connected with my heidi
you see it's here i can create a project 1
and 2 finished ie as a view the slide
puts yours in your design
perceived and done at this point
once I create it for security and
I have already created here it opens
here it is, sorry here, the la opens
console of your app as you see
this is the new google cloud console
so however the new version of the
first there was another console
here are a whole series of
information about your project
and then if you click here app engine
go to open the specific section
for app engine because inside the
same project you can also put on
all other cloud technologies you can
decide which google enable short
here do a little bit of everything
once you open the app part
engine you get this thing here that a
people we saw before as you see me
gives some statistics and tells you and then
we will understand what I am here
below in the lower part that is now
going up we find those that are a bit
all the various quotas consumed as
you see these are and the free screws
ok so you can see that i'm not for
example for the network you have a gigabyte e
every day for the computation sees a
tot of hours of viewing room etc.
more or less these are rejected at
10 Italian then every day at 10
to take oneself aside from head we go to
see how 15 3 is our first
application
I have my eclipse here. I already have the
plugin app engine installed faith ie ie
this g here in front
here it is then seen at this point
that I have the plugin installed if I do
new and I go up to give you see me here
a google and / or web entry appears
application project which application
project
ok i hope you see ok here i can
put project name and packaging
put what you want
what people here use what
you want based on how you are
therefore working the java standard then
to be able to fine tune point returns
what you want here goes well i am
eclipse settings and then whether to create
the project in the box space or from
another part
and here we begin to see the first le
first the first own configurations
for appengine app engine included
however the support with then in
In this case, however, I take it off because not
I need it and then here it is, it uses the app
engine and also put the version
the one you have at runtime this here
eclipse and already configures it all by itself
then you can already put your own feet
of opening is what I created here
from this here design of hd via
this appears projects of you colleague
of your status app and developing
boiling hicks with the project you have
created here on the cloud console then
then when you're going to deploy
application from inside the gleeks
automatically the gay locations will go on to say
ok this student follows this is yours
perfect appeals here I have to put yours
runtime and directly deploy
you can then also have other fields ad
example the use of cloud storage e
many other positive ones
you can also generate code from
example and then appengine of gray
an application for example very much
simple but already how to say of
already clarifies the basics
of the platform and here it is this one
I've already done some for you
everything then how app engine works
app engine uses the standard you see
the child character of you use it
standard java http serves lett then you
you need to extend an http server class
and then answer the 2nd place
so this is the very basis
minimum to start then the user goes
on a certain vrl to this vrl for
example matches this piece of
code then we will see how to associate it and
this piece of code does things in
this case
you see that pretty much the 7 type of
reply to text and write hello
ok specifically
we return here every app app
engine to a very important dinner file
this is the most important one
of all that defines precisely what is the
behavior of the pa and then says
when the user arrives on the domain
so in this case today glauber comp
punto up spot.com you serve this file
index.hu ml
let's get index.hu ml and see
which is an html is very simple
ok there is a title, etc. then here is a
link that opens beautiful is that puts me
with this name therefore practically
when i bleyl when the user
will click here will go on the rl is it
let's see what it corresponds to
this url which however always in the file
and look at a little but here is one but one
mapping that says when the user goes up
nice opened this black series with me
this name and this name here
corresponds to this class that looks
case it is just the class we were
looking first
ok so now if i start
I expect everything to start
I'll show you how I'm doing
leave the whole place so I have mine
development server that is created that
will be available at this address here
therefore an instance of a is graded
server very similar to what the
platform and if I'm going to this
address
I see what I have available
I'm going to copy this way
I open it here and this was it
excused a demo I have already seen
the group here in milan a few days ago
then reshuffle the change and if I click
see below here you can see little anyway
that address is beautiful and rich or
the world what we have seen before
which is in the code of course if I here
I go into the code I take off the world and there
I put something else to it
example this this the firm comment
all
I lost a piece
Oh well
here it is
ok black to the window stopped all the
I restart this is broken down
I go back and open this page e
this time or see you see a little one
but the idea is that I have mine again
message that now ostomate and this is
just the base and now if this page is
is visited by 5 10 100 million
you people need not worry
of course, to write something beautiful
something is not that it is proper
let's say the application that gives more
everyone's satisfaction we go to see
how to start complicating things
no development manages to have the re
deploy static pages then type
annoying of the html it immediately goes beyond in
java still this thing is not ok here
colleges and spi according to me yes all
you know if there is ok then yes then
let's go as I told you to see some
something very slightly more complex
at no we see the last beautiful part done
this application
I want to give to the whole world I want to do it
from all my appeal as I do
click here I always go up on the item
google that was created specifically
from the plugin and from all on the fly to app
engine
as I told you before in
project set the name
application I tied with
this tooth on eclipse and he knows then
how to make the association automatically
the branded code plugin compiles it there
he does all those things he has to do
upload in the cloud and and automatically
I will have my application available now
let's see first to be sure
what is my name bastad and I go here
under google under app engine eog
cloud.com test ok so then see here
there is also a version is a bit versions
which I told you before however we have a
see how it works then I do
google by plauto app engine I go with the
blog
he takes all his things now
compile and I will have available on
cloud dev.com test point ap spot
ap sport.com this is definitely not
written like that
he takes it from me to the one you see here
if I peak
this application if it is no longer local
to be able to see worldwide, etc. here
we have a version number then me
I explain real things, however, it serves reality
we could also take it off
and so now we go now another
version then there because always the
mess I made with giulio statue
already ahead then let's see how
do things a little more
complex we open this page here is the
first thing we say everyone teaches us
never mix the logic part with
the presentation part then you
you can also put all that
must appear on your html page
inside that code that server that
we have seen however we say that it is a lot
ugly and also very difficult
keep etc. and so on
then we begin to separate the part of
logic from the presentation part ok
pina appengine as well as being able to provide you
a server in backhand so you do
all your work exposes with
of the most rai via cloud and then if there
will then show alex also all one
part of front end so it could do
just from the web server for what
you want to serve so here is you
you can then use jsp already
You can also turn the template page
use your back end has been created
with cloud endpoints then with del
rest the ipods and also use not
so englehart js on the front end that
consumes the most exposed from your back
end then actually what there
put in front of you really is between you
the other as you can as I said before
they can be used like many others
bricks then as we have seen here
there is already the whole part to do the there
already the whole part to do the part of
web server then or for example mine
folder with images or a series d
do similar things but you can too
milo that the web server elsewhere
and put your application there
consumes and exposed services of yours
back end realized in app engine
here you have also here separates the two
so things really are very flexible
it's up to you to decide how you want
do it anyway in this specific case
what did I do?
I created two java template pages then
not server page because I like it anyway
more always remove the logic from the
code for in here
I told him look what you need to render
rwe these parameters that will arrive to you
from the back end ok sky be for this
page here that we see for that other
but just how it all works
then we always start from our web
punto xml and let's see what is the
file that is served first then
when the user enters the domain mi
will show show check itself show check
ins corresponds to this serve et che
corresponds to this class that the axis
of the project then you find it easy
let's see what it does then that already
we see the use of one of the services of
what app engine makes available is the
user service you want to do
an application that has its own
that is, its users
you can safely make the
your authentication system then
the resistable sernet password storage
safely at this rate
protection from external attacks and 150 thousand
other things or app engine integrates
natively with users of google e
for google oxford domaines then the
your gmail users to understand each other or
if you have a google app domain if with i
your google app domain teeth
so you won't have to manage
no other password etc. always the
usually talk a whole series of
services are integrated there you arrive
right away though if you want you can anyway
do what you want
in this specific case this user
service factory that creates me one says
service and from the jis service user service
I go to see these in more which
the current user has lengthened if not
is
for safety this user service
if you access your gmail account
it is not that he then has access to yours
profile on google plus or your mail
or else has granted access to yours
username then your username
nickname that is often the same
and to your email
enough then here from here you can
just take username and substantially
mail finished which says ok though
I'm using a gmail user is not that
then I expose to the world all that
there is only this in my profile
two things
so what the code does here checks
if the user authenticated or not
there are so many ways to control it
I could also use user service point
see here we have several months user
logged in so I can both check
if the user when he arrived on this
page is logged using this
service method or for example
going to see directly in the king
quest if there is already a user for this king
so here too there are several
mode then if yes let's go to
examine the code if the user is signed
I get his username creates one
collection of places in this case I have
made just a quick memory thing
but here your logic can go
as defined it takes it from a db la
he took around the world and so on
etc. and I put these attributes
inside the hard this is therefore m
current user put placement logout rl e
rigid this quest out of place there a
this gsp here in itself point gespi se
the user is not logged in compile this
this attribute which is login new rl and la
stiff to user not love her gespi after
that I do for words and I say ok
this thing sends here on the page
so see how I put one here already
logic to go and get the data that
I need
and then however all the rendering then the
I display these data and delegate them
it has a page on clumps
then html in this case
let's see the pages we take
user not logged that the simplest
as you see instead only a location
to do above the rest is everything
html codes normalissimo except that
this piece here that enters here
the rendering mechanism of the game is in play
java template page and then put them here
that attribute we saw before
so if I'm going to be a spider
my application
ok
obviously being under eclipse you have
also the possibility of doing in the bug
so you put break point and then
you see the code by hand examine the
code examine the status of your
application as it is performed
then here again the sky come back on
my localhost and here it is that has
played at moncalieri will know
certainly a famous one rarely in the picture
and tells me that you can always log in
log in this login if I go here
you see is the dynamically created login
unfortunately small however created
dynamically from my logic like
strategic is redirected here
on the page I tell myself about the logins
since I am in the deployment server
becomes presenting a screen of
login fake otherwise it would come
the authentication screen with the
your google account or if you are
already logged in I don't even get ways
pass directly I put the name of the user
in this case I put I don't know alfredo here
you can put what you want
and here we go to take that one
other page check in
see that there are rome and london with
two cities I had loaded inside
of my page and now I can
also logout this is
an image that I didn't put in
management logic but it is an image that
is directly in the front end part
wishing I could say then on the side
back end loads to the image that a
this vrl here so anyway here I can
do 150,000 here is this very example
simple I just needed to make you
understand as if how you can separate the
rendering logic of that logic
because otherwise they would hit with app
engine as I do as I do not have to
to keep everything inside, etc.
you have a thousand solutions and this is one
of the thousand available or for example
in python there is all django then
use all the template logic of
django there is also another engine of
rendering template in short, the choices
there are quite a few here too
I can do something nice that it is
the deployment however this time instead
then this one is always the same
the applications and therefore the same
application he was using
first this time I go with the
version 2
ok i'm deploying people 2
ok he now takes everything as before
what he has to take is examining
a little his things and in the same serve
then to the same address
I will have version 1 of the application e
version 2 of the application that later
simultaneously exist app
engine takes care of versioning
of the runtime code that you
upload if you also use the date
store or other things of course that
you have to think about inventing a
different mechanism, therefore if in the
version 2 clean all the database is
normal that you also clean the tracklist
of version 1 so be careful with that
that you do however with certain strategies
you can still separate them
everything now see here this time is 2
I go with the login I am already signed because
it was my user he was using
to deploy first and here I have
checked in Rome and London
now to see that indeed it is so
I go here on google.it also okay
then you will see that I am already signed with
a new doodle today then let's see what
there is
you see that I am also already stretched with
my test user what
I'm using to do the tests for
show them that it's really something
real you see that now they are not there is not
plus the sign
so what the logout is really
as if you are using a login
normal logout within the whole
google domain
ok google and google app for domaines
so if you have to do the same
speech
at this point, however, we have done the
login breathes already done the lockout
dwell
ok let's go to browse inside the
my application I go here and see that
the dashboard is reloaded e
above all I am told that for
example in the last we see three hours
this was the traffic generated here
ok if you all connect to now
that address we see earlier is not
do because then we have another more
nice to connect to practically
so they are shown to me
show everything that happens
I am shown the consumption of the
resources as you see is that is okay
obviously the application does nothing
therefore practically apart from a minimum of
static fi that are those two images
which we have loaded and little else is not
that all the rest is consumed however
it is useful to see then also all
the logs etc log consob and then
questions up here clear excellent
then let's quickly see what
there's bunello world when you create
an app a google col. application
console is told me if you want pre already
upload one of one of the two demos
available a demo is photo photo photo
share up is another is mobile back end
this first photo feed excuse java up
this first demo is nothing more than a
application that president 1 the opposite
photos and others can comment
on the photos super innovative service at
however, a lot comes today
useful to understand already a whole series of
reasoning that can be done with
this platform to do it you there
I show super fast
create a new project go here
oh well this project is fine here
violet generated automatically it takes
a moment to create it anyway then when
enter the project tells me I can do you
directly the blog of one of the
samples and you
ok and he is already doing the deployment directly e
I for convenience or already created an eccolo
here, however, I already have a project
see here is the sample you do
click here or here that I am
two available and he what does it take
already all the runtime does the
deploy links and more life to go
to take as an example the project where
there is the code where there is everything I have done
all for you I have already taken the code of the
project downloaded it and opened it
inside ibx and inside the vips meanwhile it
make up so we don't waste time later
is this here
here it is as you already see a project
a bit of articulate that contains a little
more than six roulette etc.
this project has a very thing
bellina which is a pattern that allows you
to choose how to manage storage of
your data so you can use a
database no sequel then the given a
app engine store than what comes
default if using a cloud sequel
than another piece of the cloud
platform that allows you to have the
your special sequel database ever
sequel to the cloud so you can
choose whether to do everything using a
pergine or if you lean back
well sequel and this pattern 123 these
training space here define
through a series of interfaces and
generix how to then runtime go to
choose one of two data providers
nice to see why they are there anyway
two collective in what, however, there
then it is interesting to go and see how
the service the service this already done
the deployment g cloud dev.com punto spot.com
so we go here point up spot.com
here is our photo sharing demo this
is of another fear that I had done the
people have already uploaded some
imagine if you want go ahead to this
address with your phone has
started uploading photos or the
your computer
so we see that then here in real time
they are updated and above all there
we find some traffic so we go
to see then nice things about
statistics this demo that this
we have the pattern open here
which I told you before is one thing
particularly nice to the management
of images
because it says ok how do I memorize
pictures
other things uploaded by user app
engine provides a whole
set of tools to make it a lot
very easy and substantially so
we have two we have the blog store that is
a kind of storage for files that don't
they may be sequential institutions
other things so he throws that into it
that looks like text images or others in
this case images
we have an email service lines g service
if you put a giant image for
example allows you to generate a tab
mail on the fly so you don't have to
go and resize yours
image and say ok now I need 400
800 and 600 so I have to memorize
these three images but beams of the minis
tell him then service
then there is the blog store that has an image
thousand per thousand
ok now i need 200 x 200 apple servants
this greatness
in fact we go if I then go to see
vr l ok this would be the image in
full screen is however we can see then
as also are generated here is here
there were also others etc. then
we quickly see the code of this one
app is the service part then the
upload part
here you can explore them a bit to see how
it is done however it simply comes
created a vrl to upload
then through this blog for service
you leader appengine give me 1 rl you
you will use to upload my
image therefore he already knows everything there
exposes a real with some options that
could be I don't know you put one in
cloud using google cloud storage
rather than internally and back to me
this user will upload the image
on this when the url happens when
the image of the image upload
it is managed by people there from the app engine
when the image upload is
finished you will be called a few
what then another war l there
will allow for example to save lynch
sorry to save the date
image to do all your
work etc. and so on
so then very much
easy you don't have to think about how
instead to generate the Tamil
even here I start from a birth practically
from an image service
I have a blog key then
first uploaded the image to the image
is managed by the engine that returns to it
the key to the blog store where the image
you memorized this key you can
putting it in 150,000 is up to you
in this specific case therefore return neither
key then I go to create go to
tell him that he creates this object here
options I tell you for example I want
the image that has this dimension
I want the image collapsed or
resized and he on the fly with
thanks to these ingenera mail service
a url to see get serblin scream with
the options you have passed will need 1
rl which contains the image you have
decided to put little baby big
crusade resized with maybe one
color depth and minor because
maybe you want it to be lighter
so here is one of many
services you can also here if you want
create your engine the boss
algorithm for resizing images
you are free to do it app engine
however, he already puts it at your disposal
however it is up to you to choose this
service or to implement it because
maybe you have special logics and
this is for example used to do
watermarking machines
images when so maybe there
overlap something in short then
so many processing can be done
let's see if anyone has it here
shouted something as you were
fiddling perfect then to this
point
back to our cloud console e
let's see our project on
app engine I take it here track and see
that's in the dashboard
it takes a moment to load it
because here I am already laughing
this one then we see for example
in the last 30 minutes
see there are for example peaks of
use and tells me that for example I have
already consumed a certain amount of my band
available tells me that they are already there
state of sweaty reed operations
stories like things
in the data store, they wear sequels
that just use with app engine a
which you very interface with
simple that allows you to understand all
the objects that are immunized to
its inside then you also have the logs you can
see which job clans are running
you have task views id the cures are
another thing about app engines in the sense
that you when the user arrives on an rl
by definition this must be
served within 60 seconds because why
for scalability needs and also for
the speech of a tooth waits at 2
60 seconds in front of a page
it's generally 30 seconds ago already
passed to the next page
so you can also say ok I do
a page that is what maybe
I write then waits in the background
these pockets are thrown in pockets
do their thing and then the result of
these pockets through is already absolute of
the other techniques that are there can
be displayed on the page on which
in front of which the user is one of
these
a way to send a pocket in the background
and general task you with job
I think you all know it for example in
this in this app
there is a chrono job that runs every night a
a certain time is
here, however, we see that there are the
there are various entities there are comments
the photos so for example take here
and he returns with all the users
these things can obviously be seen here
only the administrator of
the application is therefore only one then
go online once it's lengthened
he sees them, I can see them because they are
the person who deployed you can
also assign a certain number of other accounts
then as an administrator then you can
have an account that manages the app e
delegate some permits and can
create administrative pages in the
your app is only who it is
administrator will be able to access that
peace therefore flexibility
quite large I told you about the crohn jobs
this is a great job that is performed
every night at midnight also sees the
with job simply a rl when
this is called will match one
serves as what we have seen
first and the serve you can follow her
things and comfortable certain care on job can
also run for up to ten minutes
because he feels pockets in the background
however they have more freedom because up to
ten minutes always in this case for
the needs for scalability because this
is a platform that can scale then
if every user who uploads a photo to us
for example we add the watermark
it takes over ten minutes over
means that if there are 100 thousand users
that are reaching 100 thousand photos
he had practically lasted after a while
all available resources because yes
no nice google infrastructure scale
megagalattics all over the world however like
we know there is a physical limit to everything
then to continue to maintain the
scalability and speed of
platform however it is necessary to give
of the constraints by which the
platform can climb anyway
you solve them easy because you can
launch for example ask or with job
concatenate therefore when you see a
piece of processing launches ad
another that continues from where that
piece was finished and this in the end
also good because with this type i
approaches also manage to hold the
quite compact code and exit
so also to test it very well a lot
quickly all the server
of
local and also very useful to do for
revive your tests because when
I started doing gen unit of yours
application or other goes on the server e
follow everything you need to follow
and then the server is closed so no
you must necessarily make the unit law
deploy etc. you can do others
test types in this case but you can
also test everything locally then
you can also do developing tdd
an application bra appengine then me
I more or less tell you just that
then this is the application we have it
vista va well yes there was this stuff here and
we have seen all this code
then if you want more and more advanced
I can recommend the cloud and bones
which then Alex will also talk about just
after me and that allows you to create
of clothes 3p ai without writing code
but simply putting some
annotations above your classes and is
the example of those two we saw
just big the application presents
these serious point is mobile back end that
offers you a lot of infrastructure
simple to make yours communicate
mac back end with the mobile client also
to sending data from the client to the server
and both the server alerts by push
notification your clients informed
being a database in the sequels is that
what do you want and therefore already with this
skeleton you have a minimal one
infrastructure to create
a client server application where
to be able to exchange messages that type
chat application or do some things
more elaborate
there is also this video that you still have
I recommend to see what explains you
use all these things here and how
I told you there is always the starter pack
so if by any chance you have developed
your app on app engine vi
you realize that you are going beyond
free daily limits however
through this this link this code
managed to get a thousand euros of
credit code per thousand dollars
sorry for app engine credits and
$ 1,000 of computer credits
gene and resources are on the link that
I make his representations then
then there are much more advanced papers
many discussions on how to use apps
engine etc.
I'd say that's all